stroke much in real slow when I'm lying
and I was laughing super hard and gone
that was dying the name of the album is
I killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and behind
you why isn't it
it's a weird one nothing at a place no
murder weapon and no motive there's such
the couple lying dead in their bed the
proof is always out there detectives
you just have to know where to find the
pudding excuse me sir you can't be here
that's the crime scene
it's okay
he's the greatest sex crime investigator
in history
if it isn't detective Chuck Vaughn
detective Sally Ferguson we could use a
genius right now Tom Samwell
[Music]
got Samwell well uh Vaughn we've got
ourselves a hard case here all we've got
is two bodies both dead naked one man
one woman in the bed two scented candles
by the nightstand how did you
no sign of forced entry
he loved the way they smelled
he wanted to cross the threshold the way
they had on their wedding day
Dirty Dog
he would have experienced that pleasure
right here
anniversary a couple was together for a
while wanted to spice things up
check the date on the photograph
Vaughn's right today was their 15th
wedding anniversary this is huge and
what the [ __ ] was that you just pulled
your dick out and started jerking off at
the crime scene Samwell
he's the best there is by putting
himself in the perpetrator's mindset
he's able to solve crimes that involve
sex back this up some call it a blessing
small like a curse is that what it feels
like
threesome
he wanted to see them didn't you you
wanted to watch
25 feet from the bedroom across from the
kitchen
[Music]
he didn't want to see their flesh yet
did you no
no he stood
right here
[Laughter]
foreign
check the logs
[Music]
got a bloody fire poker we've got our
murder weapon
um why do your Revelations require
masturbation why do kittens require milk
no not the same thing hey hey
he's the most brilliant goddamn
detective I know put your ego aside and
give on his space my ego we've got
Captain PUD puller flinging his fluids
all over the crime scene wait
he knew them
they were closed so close too close he
he
I think he knew the house I
thought
why
what did you want you sick bastard
what he saw every day
only closer
closer
[Music]
he was close to home
all right let's go get him go go
come on
that was amazing I'm sorry
that I doubted you your methods are
unorthodox but
I cannot argue with your results
no hard feelings uh no no not gonna do
that
give yourself up Carlo why would I do
that
when I have your mind
[Music]
give yourself up Carlo
I'm right here Detective
or am I over here
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
mirror mirror all on the wall
who's the fairest of them
you are under arrest
for the murder of Mary Deeley
Meg Foster
and one detective Mason Jimenez
Now where's the girl
oh Detective
you assume it's the real me standing in
front of you
but maybe that's just what I want you to
see
when in reality the real me
is safe in a hidings for her
okay that's the real you all right
or maybe I'm over here no no you're not
over there Carlo I'm only going to ask
you one more time where is the girl go
ahead and shoot Detective
I mean what do I care if you get seven
years bad local you know it's not safe
to keep a gun cocked like that even if
you are just pointing it in the mirror
turn around and put your hands on your
head
now for that you really are going to
have to find the real man are you
kidding me
what why would you shoot a mirror Carlo
it's you I'm holding your lapel now
you're done it's over you're gonna cut
your hand on that broken mirror
where is she
say it dude say what
say you don't know whether or not this
is the real me or just a reflection in
the mirror
weekly
okay I don't know whether the you I'm
holding on to is really you for the
reflection or our reflection in the
mirror
shoes on the before boards by the
intross
I win detective
you I told you but I mean the mirror
told you but what you know
oh
[Music]
first things first I do not care that
you're a multi-platinum selling rapper
gun rack
what I care about is that I 100 know
that you murdered Darnell Simmons so you
better start talking
[Music]
yeah but you ain't got Mom
okay
you know I'm actually I'm very glad that
you said that
because I respectfully
I beg to differ
now yeah I shot him with my knot I shot
him nine times nine pm on the dime and
by the way it was November 9th
[Music]
that don't mean nothing
I got a vivid imagination
[Applause]
I couldn't have sat down now
I was at my cousin's birthday party
Red Lobster November 9th
at Red Lobster geez I gotta tell you gun
right I find that really hard to believe
when in reality I shot dark nail like a
monster it's a lot anyone could tell
this if you know about my allergy to all
shellfish
just confess conrack
I confess that shellfish is the only
thing that rhymes with tell this
s just bars
[Music]
those adjectives
they just happen to be in adult order
but
man got no pearl
now with a long-ass gun and tossed it
into the aquarium
I have no idea what that object is
if I had to identify it I would call it
a gun of the long ass variety some
seaweed in there too look the tattoo I
had to break it to you
struck my chin real slow when I'm lying
and I was laughing super hard as Darnell
was dying the name of the album is I
killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and behind
you coincidence you're going away for a
long time you understand you're gonna
get Festivus the last thing you'll ever
do you hear me come back
he's free to go what no no no no we have
everything we need no Sims girlfriend
she just confessed to the whole thing
infidelity crime of passion
let's go Mr rack
[Applause]
[Music]
bonus track I got a ride or die [ __ ] I
think you get the gist and when you let
me out I'm gonna blow a little kiss this
is My Confession
it's a bowling Court I killed Darnell
Simmons for sport
that's right I'm a murderer come get me
come down the hall you can't get me okay
okay you got me dummy ow
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
just wanted to come say hello that's it
that is all have a nice night so where
are you going girl you can't leave
without coming inside
oh no I wouldn't want to be an intrusion
I just wanted to say hello goodbye there
is a seat in this house with your name
on it girl no no no no no no no no no no
no I can't I didn't have money for the
bus I'm a mess from the 50 mile walk
must you be so difficult girl you're
right I am being difficult aren't they
your life is better without me coming in
trust me so there I go okay girl listen
everything is irie man we're good
friends it's all right of course you
know you can smell it girl you know you
smell it girl you know you're smelling
the fried dumplings
I'm formally inviting you into my home
now come inside
[Music]